everything always looks like a disaster
right we've done this oh my god our
clients say that
we're not gonna make it we have to fire
someone and everything
if you look at it in the test of you
know like a long period of time
everything works out
[Music]
thank you so much for being on my show
20 minute leaders how are you
great thanks for inviting me of course i
have to say that it's a beautiful
balcony that we have over there
in in tel aviv but i have to start with
actually your fun fact which is the fact
that you play the ukulele
and you showed it to me just a second
ago behind you there
we started with that fun fact
now i you know i i know how to play what
a wonderful world i taught myself that
it took me about three years to learn it
and but so i have a lot of respect for
the fact that you you claim that you've
played the ukulele
but i wanna i wanna spend these 20
minutes talking about you
and your journey as we get to that the
climax of the conversation
uh your most recent company walnut i'd
love to go back in time and
you know to your 20s sales marketing
leadership starting your own businesses
new york city tel aviv
walk me through your journey because i
think there's a lot to a lot of lessons
to be learned about
your entrepreneurial journey
right um so i started my career like by
accident when i was 22.
i wanted to do freelance marketing for
startups and
you know like 10 years ago the startup
nation was a little bit smaller so there
was room to do that and be the first one
so um i did that and it turned out to be
the biggest company in israel to do that
so we had like 500 clients
um dozens of employees and offices in
manhattan and london
um i also lived in london and manhattan
like you know periodically
and it was a lot of fun and after seven
years of being the ceo
i decided i needed to do something more
um you know
something different like but you have
you're skipping over all over the juicy
parts
you're 22 years old how do you get to
run a company that has over 500 clients
with
offices and three continents i don't
understand that
you know i always try to think of a good
word to say
you know i was a very shitty ceo to
start with
you know i had i had employees that were
like double my age and they had kids of
their own and
i've made every mistake possible but it
just
you know it's what the what we love in
israel the university of life
you have to go through it much more than
any other
and right just worked out so
going back what were some of the most
monumental moments
or your aha moments as you're going
through
this company and you're managing the
company for for seven years what were
some of the most incredible milestones
that you'll forever keep with you
um i think the first one is
uh quit your job because i had a very
i had a very good job when i was like 21
22 when i came back from my
my after army trip which was a year long
in central america
and i had a really good job like my
friends were like how the hell did you
get the job
while we're trying to figure out where
we're going to study for the next four
years
um but i just quit it because i wanted
to be like you know be my own boss
so right that was probably the smartest
move i've
ever made and it changed my life yeah
yeah and the other thing is don't worry
about being a very
a very um a very bad founder and a ceo
when you're in
early twenties that's when you have to
make all the mistakes
but when you get a little bit better and
older and better and older
um then you're gonna be amazing and
much and have much better background and
people who have done
an amazing degree and you know they were
vps at some enterprise companies you're
probably going to beat them
in being a founder so from your
experience
what are some of the most you know
important things one
can do as a young entrepreneur
first-time entrepreneur
and in owning those mistakes and you
know obviously we're all going to make
mistakes and i'm looking forward to
making
many more mistakes that i'm already
making as i go through my
entrepreneurial journey but what do we
need to do in order
to keep that in mind and to own them and
to fix them
and you need to start by doing them
and then um you know building a startup
it's like every day it's a worst mistake
than before
every phase of the startup so i have to
do it
and if you don't do it you know it's
like in the gym if it doesn't hurt then
you're not
you're not improving so that's the only
way
you need to find yourself people that
you become and you can
give them a call give them what's up
message you know annoy them
and ask them ask them for uh you know
usually people that are just a bit older
from you they have like an experience
running a company
a little bit better than you um surround
yourself with those people
and you know eventually everything
everything always looks like a disaster
right we've done this oh my god our
clients say that
we're not gonna make it we have to fire
someone and everything
if you look at it in the test of you
know like a long period of time
everything works out you just got to be
a little bit less emotional
right okay so so then let's continue on
your journey
you're seven years in you have hundreds
of clients
and what are some of the most important
insights to learn about about marketing
and pr
through that experience
now you're taking a topic that can be 10
hours and you're asking it
one question um that's that's the intel
that's that's what's so smart about this
show because i get to now skip
nine hours of studying for that one
sentence that everybody's looking for
now of course there's no magical answer
no i have a lot
i i would say that you know i was also
like an advisor in most of the different
accelerators that you probably know and
i think what i usually told
the founders in terms of of early stage
marketing
is that you got to try and be your own
so if you're the ceo of the startup and
you start building your own reputation
like you create
guest articles on the big publications
um
you know at some point of time of my
life i was writing for
like 10 u.s publications uh really
yeah you know like cnbc forbes fox
so you might not be able to do all of
that but you can definitely
work on a couple of uh channels that
will brand you as like the founder of
that company
and then when you need to raise your you
know announcement i've raised
see all that you're gonna be already
close to the media
so you're not
that's actually that's actually a really
really good tip i'm going to keep that
in mind and i think it's a
you know i i keep following um both
the writing that you did and you do but
also other people that are writing
and and it always makes it makes me an
age that i i really want to get into
that because it's not just about
you know getting your name on those
publications but it forces you to think
critically about some topics
and to put that thinking into words that
can be meaningful for others
so i think that it's it's definitely
something that i'm that i'm looking
forward to so so you're running these
publications you
you have that you have that agency with
hundreds of clients and
what's next on your journey on the way
to becoming you know
the ceo of walnut
so i you know i was in new york for like
almost a year
and i just realized that being a
marketing company is nice but if you
don't have 200 employees in your own
building
but american uh audience and companies
they don't really give a so
i had to i understand it really
encouraged me to
start thinking about my next moves um
so i came back to israel and i took some
time off it was a very long
seven years i took some time off
and and then he formed the startup that
was designed to save kids from
pedophiles on social media right like
right so it was me and three more
founding
that people members know um and
you know after a year of doing that
which is a great cause and i hope they
succeed
um just i felt that it's perfect time
for you know corona started people
started switching their mindset
and i just realized alright now is the
perfect time for me to start my own
thing again
and i'm the founder co-founder ceo and
um and that was the beginning of walnut
so so i want to hold on on this junction
because
now you're at a point in time where
you've had an agency that you have
you've had a very successful business
you grew with your bare hands
in three continents with dozens of
employees and offices
you've seen what that journey is like
and what selling and
getting to a good product is like then
you're part of a founding team
of a company that is growing very very
quickly raised a lot of money with a
very
a well-known and respected ceo with a
great cause
and you're deciding to go back to the
drawing board
and to create a company from scratch
walnut
was it that you just had to you know
create something of your own
like have your own baby was it that you
were look that you wanted
to really see what it's like to be that
ceo of a hyper growth startup what was
it that
really attracted you
um that's an amazing question i think it
was it was a combination of
um i think everyone life has changed a
little bit
like seven months ago or eight months
ago um
and for me i felt you know the change
uh the main the main thoughts that i had
while we were
qualified very much were that i have to
do
my own thing again i have to name it i
have to decide what the product is gonna
do
um and it just felt right you know i
don't really know how to explain it
but it just felt right where's steve
from before with your
job always so um i i decided that i'm
gonna
pursue what i'm feeling and you know
everything kind of like all of the stars
aligned ever since it was
really starting off in the right foot
i have to say that i'm drawing a
parallel to a lot of the other
interviews that i've had on this show
and almost every guest comes with a
non-linear
career path and almost always the
recurring theme is that they've had this
gut feeling
like the one you're describing that says
you know michael i can't really explain
it in words
i had to do it that it was it's like you
know they say that that entrepreneurs
are crazy and i think that's part of the
insanity
right feeling like you have to go with
your heart
right so i left my previous startup and
um danny my co-founder who is a
brilliant technology guy and
he sold like two startups and then he
oversaw
like 70-something developers at wework
um he kind of was
looking for you know wework is i don't
know kind of imploded and
he was looking also to start his next
thing and
we started um we started
it wasn't a matter of ideation which is
the process that i hate the most when
you're starting your company
because it's a never-ending process
right there's no due date right
every day all day we were both kind of
excited about this whole thing of
of revolutionizing how companies present
themselves to other companies
and we just started building an mvp and
interviewed 60 enterprise companies and
saw what they would probably pay for if
we if we built
and everything just started off you know
like a
serious rollercoaster sense we're
talking so so what is the
so you mentioned very briefly this the
problem the the industry of
showing your product to others or
demoing your product and and when we had
a really nice walk
on ben gurion studio really explained to
me that the pain point behind
a team's ability to present their their
product to another team
live so talk to me a little bit about
the space and why is walnuts so relevant
in 2020
right so uh 2020 is the year where
everything's done remote so
and you know during the regular times
let's say of the previous year with four
corner
companies always have like a lot of
friction between the sales team and the
back end
so the sales team has to have the design
to design something
uh not to touch the back end so it
doesn't break uh
and you know it's it's uh it's a it's
like a cross-valuable problem
every company has a problem it doesn't
matter who you are
it doesn't matter what's your size um so
we started building like building like
an editor like you would edit a website
on wix
and it's on our cloud so you edit the
sales demo and it's
it's unbreakable because it's on a cdn
and we just started building it we
showed it to a lot of companies everyone
wanted to hire us
and then we raised seed it took us like
a month end to end from
some of the investors that i consider to
be the best around
and now we're growing the team
onboarding clients
and that that's amazing so so give me a
little bit more insight into
this product and and the actual
experience so
you mentioned that one of the
interesting solutions that you've just
that you've discovered here is that you
can actually
disintegrate the sales team from the
product and back-end team such that the
sales team can
write their own demos without having to
interface with the back-end team
and without blocking each other so and
so do is this like you know
a just like a light a demo where you
record it and then you show it or is it
a live demo
where you can play around with it
because obviously you want to play
around with the demo live in front of
clients
right so it's not a video and it's not a
screenshot and it's not a mock-up and
it's not
it's an actual dashboard it's a product
that the sales people had to dive in
like
two minutes before the call and
customized uh if you personalize
everything
um you know the only reason that netflix
beat all the big uh
you know um moving producers and uh
hollywood
hollywood directors is that because it's
it gives us a lot of customization
and we build our and it's all very
reachable
um so that's a big difference when
you're showing a product it has to be
customized to the client you're showing
me to um and we just gave them that tool
and we realized that there is too much
of a demand that we can handle because
we launched
and we got like uh almost a thousand
companies to reach out
in like wow and yeah um
and pretty much the most amazing
companies you can imagine i don't want
to name them but
pretty much the biggest enterprise
companies in the world
sometimes it was different teams from
the same company reaching out not
knowing the others that reached out
so we've proven that there's a problem
and and all of this and how long since
the inception
seven months maybe seven months that's
unbelievable so
what walk me through the first seven
months of
you know a fast-growing startup you're
the ceo
what what what's bothering you like what
what makes you
tick before you go to sleep
my phone
[Laughter]
um you know it's like a never-ending
it's a never-ending you know people
don't know you seem too calm you're too
relaxed
you're like i'm nervous for you you're
growing so
fast you're on boarding more employees
you have a thousand companies waiting in
line
and you're sitting there relaxed and
saying yes i'm enjoying it
yeah i had something to drink before we
got on this side
um i'll learn that for the next one
no if you if you're pressured and if
you're relaxed you're gonna reach pretty
much the same outcome
so i have i have no choice but during
the day like you know
it's not what like 9 pm at night during
the day we're working in a
in a roller coaster like everyone's
working their ass off
and you know at night we talk to the
american companies investors and
everyone right yeah you know it's a lot
of fun i think it's the most fun i've
had in all of my career
honestly that that that's it's so fun
and inspiring for me to be talking to
somebody
who's already had a marvelous career and
and is impacted in so many organizations
and now you're saying that
that literally now is the most fun
you're having and that just makes me
want to go and start
start my own thing already what
surprised you over these
seven months what caught you off guard
that you're like ah
wow i didn't realize this before
um i was afraid you know because it's
because it was like a crisis and people
were holding on to
their jobs um that
it's gonna be hard for us to recruit
like the you know the talent and
now it's easier because we are about us
and we raise money but before we
actually
raise the money i was really surprised
at how people were loyal to working
you know joining our team like our
founding team even before there was the
first investor in
the first client was in and we're very
grateful to them you know some of the
best people i know they have like 10 15
years on the road in the industry and
i'm really proud of the team that we've
built um
now it's going to be harder because you
know when you're done working with your
first
circle of friends or friends you're
starting to grow and be you know 10 15
20 30 and you gotta you gotta hire
people
you don't know your friends don't know
your colleagues don't know and it's
getting to be more uh
you know scary but um also it happened
to me too like
two times already before so i hope it
will be um
i hope it will be fine again right and
you know usually at this
point of the conversation i ask what is
some advice you would give to a young
entrepreneur like myself
as i am gearing up towards starting my
own but i but what i'm taking away from
this conversation is both
you know quit your job especially if it
means following your heart and and if
you're doing something because
sometimes not always but sometimes the
end result is you're able to say that
you're having the most fun you ever had
in your life
or in your career and this is and
obviously you know
anybody who's looking at the stats of
what you've been doing the past seven
months can see
what an incredible journey this has been
for you especially during a crisis that
that basically you know immobilized most
of the
startups in the world uh so so i think
that's pretty exciting
before we go though i have to ask for
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
or three words that your co-founder or
one of your
team members would use to describe you
um should have done my homework and
prepare some
no no spontaneous is the key three words
um i would say emotional
i didn't expect that yeah not in my
personal life but when building a
startup
i'm very emotional which is not good
i think my co-founder you know i think
my team members would
would use a name to describe me let
someone that's uh making it complicated
to order lunch
enough deciding and
um and also a little bit being late to
places all the time
but besides that i think i'm a really
decent guy
you have a you definitely are and and i
very much appreciate our friendship and
and i learned a lot from you so thank
you for both
giving the time to do this show and uh
and for and for teaching me throughout
the journey and
it's been a lot of fun following you and
i can't wait to follow walnut and things
you're doing
and and other than that i just have to
wish you to stay safe and stay healthy
likewise and good luck with your book
everyone go and buy it it's awesome
thank you take care bye bye
[Music]